buon pomeriggio a tutti e grazie a te ed
ex di avermi dato questa occasione di
essere su questo palco oggi perché mi dà
l'opportunità di trasferirvi una
grandissima idea innovativa oggi infatti
vi parlerò della moneta ecco vedo già
delle perplessità qui adesso i fari
sparati ma effettivamente la prima sly
non mi aiuta a tradurre un po
l'innovazione i contenuti innovativi e
di questa immagine pensavi di questa
immagine e risale circa una moneta
coniata nel vii secolo avanti cristo
pare la prima in assoluta l'electro in
lidi r creso ebbe l'idea ebbe l'idea di
coniare questo questa moneta in oro in
oro e argento per facilitare gli scambi
quale unità di conto per riuscire quindi
a dare alla stessa unita alle merci che
venivano scambiate poi venne adottata
nelle polis greche poi divenne la dracma
insomma di idee di successo stiamo
parlando per i contenuti innovativi e ho
bisogno magari fare qualche passo avanti
bisogno di una mano da parte vostra
tutti voi avete delle monete in tasca si
sé tante chi più chi meno
giusto hakodate mela grazie
se posso no sto scherzando però
ragioniamoci un attimo su una cosa
sapete veramente che cosa avete in tasca
sapete veramente qual è
diciamola che strumento è quello della
moneta perché in realtà ok è uno
strumento di scambio è una riserva di
valore è un unità di conto come voleva
il nostro simpatico re creso perché se
fosse veramente così
pochi anni fa senza andare millenni fa
pochi anni fa cosa e successo
questi signori qui hanno portato all
asta anche l'insegna se l'utilizzo
smodato degli strumenti cosiddetti
derivati che avevano creato un euforia
enorme nel mondo economico ci hanno
fatto andare a picco sono state
utilizzate in maniera assurdamente
speculativa e sulla nostra pelle ahimè
battuta mare abbiamo capito l'etimologia
della parola derivato è strumento
derivato quello che ci ha portato alla
deriva
allora io dico ma tutto questo che
succede sono tra l'altro a 2.000
chilometri di distanza ma cosa c'entra
con la nostra economia locale
cosa c'entra con noi cosa sempre ha
fatto che giorno dopo che nel crack
della rimembranza sono entrati in banca
direttore buongiorno salve ieri ero
venuto per il prestito guardi purtroppo
in effetti ma
perché perché a migliaia di famiglie
italiane stato negato il credito perché
a migliaia di aziende è stata tolta
liquidità in nome di questa presunta
crisi del sistema di liquidità
ma gli scienziati posti di lavoro
sappiamo tutti quello che è successo ma
se ci pensiamo bene è un paradosso
perché come se il giorno dopo nessun
produttore locale azienda locale avesse
voglia di produrre ci fossero i
magazzini vuoti nessuno aveva più voglia
di comprare ma non è così è andato in
crisi il sistema di pagamento il mezzo
di pagamento non l'economia locale
allora cosa fare
come uscirne
probabilmente se di grande crisi
finanziaria si è trattato lo sappiamo
bene beh allora pensiamo a una soluzione
finanziaria
pensiamo che è andato in crisi il
sistema di pagamento con la moneta a
corso legale beh facciamo dotare le
imprese della possibilità di crearsi un
altra moneta
questo guardato hanno pensato quattro
ragazzi sardi freschi di studi
universitari e all'estero sono rientrati
nella loro isola qualche anno fa e hanno
sviluppato un'idea imprenditoriale
proprio basandola su questo hanno
fondato il sar decs quindi l'electro era
creso laurent fondato il sad e che sono
andati al giro dell'azienda dire
guardate che potete esprimere la vostra
produttività la vostra ricchezza
adottando un altro militare di conto
guardate hanno creato un qualcosa la cui
eco è andata ben oltre l'isola ben oltre
anche i confini italiani e poche
settimane fa hanno avuto anche un
riconoscimento ufficiale uscendo un
bellissimo articolo sul financial times
eccolo qua cesar di xfactor
cosa hanno pensato questi ragazzi hanno
pensato che ieri quando è uscito dalla
banca mi scusino il signore in sala
ancorché particolarmente incassato col
direttore però magari continuava aver
fame e nel centro di bologna poteva
continuare a trovare dei ristoratori che
avrebbero cucinato per lui
probabilmente sì il problema era il
sistema di pagamento ma se ci
accorgevamo su qualcosa di diverso
poteva funzionare benissimo hanno messo
a terra e secondo me questa è la forza
di un'idea innovativa e se in grado di
mettere la terra a favore dell'economia
locale
la famosa stanza di compensazione
cos'è la stanza di compensazione ma
guarda te è molto semplice perché vedete
c'è un operatore a che probabilmente ha
un debito con un operatore b che
probabilmente un debito con l'operatore
si è così via ma avete capito sono
finisce il countdown ecco allora la cosa
più ragionevole e non è tanto
costringere tutti questi operatori a
pagare i propri debiti in euro che non
hanno perché c'è crisi di liquidità o
fallire cari in banca a chiedere
prestiti che le banche non vogliono dare
perché se crisi di liquidità la cosa più
ragionevole
sembra può apparire compensare le
partite di debito e di credito il più
possibile fra di loro così facendo
riducendo il bisogno complessivo di
liquidità semplice no due presupposti
fondamentali primo lavorare sulla
produttività locale delle aziende quindi
se il cosiddetto potenziale inespresso
ovverosia i posti vuoti di un ristorante
così che eri contento le camere vuote di
un albergo le ore buche di un
professionista i magazzini che non
cercano tutto ciò che il sistema in euro
il mercato in euro non riesce a far
distribuire si può distribuire adottando
questa nuova unità di conto e creando
questa possibilità di economia condivisa
si dice anche secondo presupposto
fondamentale è il titolo di questo
intervento che voi ricorderete
sicuramente vero
no cioè è la moneta della
fiducia
cos'è la moneta della fiducia cos'è la
fiducia in questo con nuovo contesto
economico significa che i operatore ho
fiducia che tu che entri nel mio negozio
compri dei miei beni non mi paghi in
euro ma mi dai la possibilità di
accumulare dei crediti che ho fiducia di
poter poi spendere nello stesso mercato
nello stesso circuito perché vero
trattato con lo stesso modo che io sto
trattando te adesso
succede una cosa straordinaria sapete in
questi mercati succede che gli operatori
economici del territorio si collegano
tra di loro e ancora non la loro
produzione a livello
succede quindi che il ristoratore
all'albergatore il meccanico il gommista
sfruttando la loro potenzialità e
produttiva e quindi il loro potenziale
inespresso fanno vendite aggiuntive che
diversamente non avrebbero fatto con la
moneta di corso legata accumulano
crediti che poi possono spendere come è
semplicemente acquistando beni e servizi
che li servono e quindi risparmiando a
loro volta euro o magari facendo
investimenti che tipicamente in in
situazioni di crisi non vengono fatti
che sono magari marche di comunicazione
pubblicità vi voglio fare un esempio
un esempio su questo molto vicino a noi
perché i sardi hanno declinato questo
loro nuovo modello economica anche su
altre regioni italiane quindi circuito
liberec spunto net come diceva danilo è
nato un anno fa in a bologna e il
circuito dell'emilia romagna va
benissimo se vuoi da suscita d'acqua ha
fatto un chilometro per andare in centro
in via mascarella c'è un cinema che
notano i bolognesi cinema o da il
circuito cinema bologna ha partecipato
al circuito libere se sono otto sale
cinematografiche e si è messo d'accordo
con altri otto dieci operatori di
circuito libris di realizzare un
carosello pubblicitario insieme troviamo
il gommista troviamo il meccanico
troviamo tutti anche operatori di media
dimensione noti in natura si che nel
circuito anziché piscine sogese accanto
del gruppo era anche altri realizzano
questo questo carosello che andrà in
onda in centinaia di spot nei mesi di
programmazione più calda che è quello
invernale simpatica questa cosa comunque
è vero tutti vanno al cinema ci sono
circa potenzialmente 300 mila biglietti
venduti in questo in questo circuito
cinema in questo periodo e hanno
realizzato questa cosa assolutamente in
crediti in liber ex
quindi è molto molto bella e molto
produttivo come funziona questa cosa
funziona molto semplicemente basta basta
abbandonare tutti i concetti sulla
moneta legale quindi noi non ci siamo
messi a bologna nell'osteria stampare
liberi nei banche non li stampano per
noi la moneta di corso legale c'è già
si chiama euro la conosciamo tutti
un euro equivale a un liberec se l'unità
di conto aiuta quindi queste imprese a
farsi credito reciproco tra di loro ma
io dico ma esiste una parola che può
essere la guida la norma di una vita
adesso non voglio scomodare i dieci
comandamenti venga dato numeri ricordo
neanche tutti però
reciprocità di operatore economico mi
comporto come vorrei che tutti
comportarsi con me e quindi ad otto
delle regole comuni molto semplici gli
stessi prezzi che applichi in euro le
applico in liberi tutti i conti partono
partono a zero sono concesse delle
posizioni di debito dove misura in cui
io come azienda riverso dei miei beni e
servizi in credito nel circuito ci sono
anche delle possibilità della luna una
struttura che facilita questi scambi
quindi vedete delle persone che dialogo
nel servizio broker con le persone
dell'azienda per fare acquisti e vendite
esiste un sistema informatico è voluto
che emette dei conti e mette delle carte
le linee di interesse interne circuito
sono sempre zero guardate
interessantissimo è
pensare a una cosa pensare che in questi
in queste in questa nuova economia
condivisi in questo nuovo possibilità di
fare economia
le posizioni di debito non si accumulano
costantemente ma si trovano
costantemente dei creditori che hanno
voglia di acquistare questo perché il
sarde si libera e come voleva il creso
non sono unità di conto non sono monete
di accumulo speculative creano fanno
girare alla ricchezza fanno girare la
produzione guardate questo dato
misura la velocità di circolazione della
moneta
allora guardate il sarde se prendiamo la
scena più strutturata evidentemente che
ha più al periodo di tempo ne è
consolidato
circle a 12,28 volte cosa vuol dire
passa di mano in mano
12,28 volta in unità di tempo che un
anno la bce emanato questa questo dato
per quel che riguarda l'euro l'euro
circa una volta e mezzo queste unità di
conto circolano dieci volte di più della
moneta a corso legale ma pensate quanta
produttività in più quanta ricchezza in
più se è vero come è vero che la moneta
misura il valore dei beni che vengono
commercializzati ben misurerà tanto più
valore
quanto più velocemente questi beni
vengono vengono transati quindi proprio
questa unità di conto come voleva il re
creso e ci sono anche già delle
applicazioni molto interessante sapete
quanti pò welfare aziendale
cosa intendiamo sono state aperte
centinaia di pronti i cosiddetti bitri
ai dipendenti delle imprese aderenti
quindi questo significa che il
dipendente ha potuto ottenere in crediti
ciò che neuro magari l'assenza faceva
fatica a ottenere quindi stiamo parlando
del diciamo del premio del benefit del
prestito uno degli esempi più evocativi
in sardegna si racconta di un matrimonio
fatto in crediti quindi ristoratore qui
in emilia replicheremo con un divorzio
fatto in crediti
visti gli ultimi dati che ci sono a
parte la battuta comunque voglio dire
questo è veramente importante questa
economia condiviso circolare come viene
chiamata solo per darvi l'entità di
questo fenomeno e ho finito il mio tempo
vi vi dico due numeri perché questi
sostanziano poi in pochi anni guardate
sarde che cosa transato a oltre 3.000
aziende iscritte oltre 1500 conti famosi
between che vi dicevo prima dei
dipendenti oltre 63 milioni di transato
più di 90 mila operazioni effettuate
però nel nostro piccolo diciamo così di
circuito liberi si difende molto bene
anzi ha ottenuto dei risultati secondo
noi da un anno di tempo a questa parte
ancora più importanti in un anno di
tempo in un aziende in start up 130
aziende hanno aderito vi sono già
presenti nel circuito 50 settori
merceologici e proprio la scorsa
settimana abbiamo superato i 500 mila
euro di transato quindi quasi mille
operazioni effettuate se non ce la
facevamo avevamo già deciso di chiede
andrea paure di spostare di una
settimana tedesca che questo dato va
assolutamente pubblicato
beh signori allora vi lascio con un
intimissima considerazione nel merito e
riprendendo la home page ricevuto
liberec spunto net e l'intera regione in
rete io da un pò di anni da un po di
tempo che mi sto occupando di questa
cosa e devo dire che è bella etica ma si
fa ci sono le difficoltà dello start up
naturale ci sono difficoltà ascoltavo
prima gli altri relatori no di uscire
dalla propria area di comfort vi rubo un
minuto in più ma questa ve la devo
raccontare quindi soprattutto
l'invasamento no dai non dirla questa la
dico perché mi riguarda allora ieri a
fine giugno vanno in un ristorante del
centro insieme non dirigente di circuito
libera se altri due collaboratori per
fare una pausa pranzo di lavoro questo
ristorante aderito noi facciamo una
pausa di lavoro il titolare si siede con
noi per il caffè perché parliamo di vari
eventi che si possono realizzare in
questo modo mi alzo va dalla cassa e
pago in euro
all'ora e tremenda questa cosa qua se
proprio l'abitudine che noi abbiamo
consolidato ma se scontate anche i
ragazzi sardi vi racconteranno c'è sul
sito alle difficoltà iniziali dei
facciate che hanno preso però poi sono
riusciti nei numeri concreti a ottenere
quello che hanno ottenuto e soprattutto
personalmente gli sarò sempre grato
perché mi hanno dimostrato una cosa
molto importante molto vera vedete
dietro queste 90 mila transazioni
effettuate queste migliaia di di
possibilita in piu e ci sono delle
strette di mano quando si conclude un
affare ci si stringe la mano quando un
buon a farci si sorride sempre allora mi
hanno dimostrato che tutto sommato il
sorriso la stretta di mano la fiducia
le relazioni tra persone valgono ancora
di più oggi di qualsiasi modello
economico o qualsiasi sistema di credito
qualcuno si voglia inventare grazie